[Music]
morgan freeman accused of sexual
misconduct by multiple women the 80 year
old actors alleged inappropriate
behavior reportedly spans throughout his
nearly five decade
sixteen people have come forward about
Freeman to CNN eight alleged victims and
eight who claim to be witnesses as part
of an ongoing investigation jump into
Paul Shapiro your third realm a
production assistant working on the
comedy going in style claims she
experienced months of harassment on set
telling CNN Freeman made advances toward
her including unwanted touching another
woman on the production staff of 2012's
now you see me accuses the actor of
sexually harassing her and her female
assistant numerous times with comments
about their bodies
Freeman released a statement to et that
read anyone who knows me or has worked
with me knows I am NOT someone who would
intentionally offend or knowingly make
anyone feel uneasy I apologize to anyone
who felt uncomfortable or disrespected
that was never my intent I got a
confession to make I don't think I'm
ever not acting Freeman currently has
multiple films in the works et has
reached out to determine whether these
recent allegations put his current
projects in jeopardy
[Applause]
[Music]